dans les médias que je l'admets j'ose
pas et elle est le thème mais je sais
pas moi mais vous vous voyez souvent
obèses auraient tous les jours alors
vous en êtes où enfin si tu es là pour
l'instant je la regarde à travers des
humains tu as raison il faut y aller
progressivement
ah oui oui mais alors là si tu veux je
me demande si elle ne m'a pas vu parce
que l'autre jour bon j'étais temps entre
65 m mais elle a regardé dans la
direction fait attention
oui alors tu m'aides bon d'accord t'as
déjà commencé à me regarder gbe paris le
et je suis coincé je n'ai pas la date
enfin il faudrait voir sur un calendrier
ah oui voilée parce que hier je l'avais
la date et aujourd'hui je vais pas
là-bas il faudrait voir à la poste
ah bon bon tu sais comment il s'appelle
bon ben alors t'as qu'a laissé un blanc
déjà ah oui quand je me fais que ça à
remplir après bah oui tu y vas bon alors
mais comment je commence attaqué la
foule était discrètement sur son
physique
harry bombages humain je dis que là des
jolies fesses
le discret commence par les nichons oui
tu peux plus parler mon métier tu mets
ton métier pour pour qu'elle te
connaisse mieux d'accord alors bon je
lui dis je suis aide volailler et jeanne
religion
e mais j'aime bien vos missions
voilà ça va la marquer à huy mal à
marquer vous avez la main et je pourrais
peut-être lui parler de mes goûts à
babré t go et et couleurs n'oublie pas
tes couleurs
ah ouais mais c'est quoi les goûts des
doigts au baptême bien flâner dans le
métro à l'est puis j'aime bien compter
les voitures ou fleurot way puis
regardez les devantures ah oui chez le
boucher
oui mais parlez-lui de ton salaire
ah ben je suis nourrie logée remettait
des têt les à côtés
bah oui alors j'ai les tickets pour les
chaussures et j'ai plusieurs cravate au
cpc peut-être pas la peine de lui dire
combien ne plusieurs c'est déjà bien
puis par le letton physique
ah oui bah alors j'étais à dire physique
physique
nouveau mais physique intéressant sur
tout le visage
martin d'un bon poitrail j'ai un bon
poids très bien reçus de les bras de
bras et puis il tente beaucoup d' henry
quand j'ai une belle terre de foot moi
ou le pied oui parlez-lui tes pieds
d'accord avec vous je m'attendais vous
ôte presse-sports le temps joue pour toi
moi je vous donne rendez-vous pour pour
jour de la toussaint alors et une fille
sa semaine vers les 7 heures du matin
non sinon ouais
alors dix ans si lui 7h20 7h30
7h30 qu'elles soient bien tard à 7h30
sur la place devant les toilettes comme
ça tu peux pas les manquer dans les
postures bercy est tellement signé wit
est pas foutu après que c'est moi